The Washington Post just exposed a
bunch of dietitian colleagues who
are being paid by junk food industry and
yes we definitely need to talk [Music]
hey everyone I'm Abby sharp welcome to Abby's
kitchen today we're going to be talking about this
piping hot tea of a Washington Post article called
the food industry pays influencer dietitians to
shape your eating habits those journalists woke up
and chose violence with a headline like that but
clearly your girl has some pretty big thoughts
so I got my tea let's chat I've been working
full-time in media for 11 years so I've been doing
brand Partnerships long before there was like any
kind of Playbook on how to do paid Partnerships I
was doing spokesperson work long before there was
any kind of like Tick Tock or Instagram reels like
but anyway I basically fumbled my way through this
kind of content creator role at the start of my
career because it was a really new phenomenon and
there were no influencers for teaching influencing
or blogs to read about blogging like influencing
did not even exist when I started I was a blogger
like do we even say that anymore now if you work
in the space at all you are a a influencer
though FYI I actually do not like that term
I don't identify with it at all I see myself first
and foremost as a dietitian who just so happens to
disseminate knowledge to the masses but anyways
I actually learned best practices by calling my
dietetic college up on the phone basically every
week so I was asking them what can I do what can't
I do what can I say what can't I say Etc and
honestly even they weren't 100 sure because
social media was just starting to take off but
anyway obviously I'm sure like I mean I know that
mistakes were made in my early days and when I
was starting out I'm sure I worked with a bunch of
brands that I definitely would not work with today
so for example when I was fresh at an internship
and I was really still exploring what kind of
dietitian I was and what I believed in I'm pretty
sure I wrote a blog post in partnership with
Weight Watchers no would I touch that today and
unless it was ripping them apart also I did a
video several years ago with MSG in partnership
with whatever commodity board makes MSG and
while I still agree with everything I said in
that video because it was heavily researched
on my part personally and I scrutinized the
out of the messaging that I was given today
I probably wouldn't partner with MSG and I
don't think that MSG is dangerous but I also
don't think that it's contributing greatly to
public health either so I took that video down
a while ago because it just no longer aligns but
yeah back when I was just starting out I didn't
have any kind of representation I had no mentors
so I was probably a lot more sheepish when it
comes to like pushing back on brand messaging
the influencer marketing World in itself was
so green like I said it didn't even exist so
I don't think that any of us had really figured
out our roles or expectations for influencers and
influencer agencies but anyways I am definitely
in a very different place a decade later so today
I have a team about 12 people helping me with
content and watching my back I've worked with
the top media coaches I've got direct contacts
with YouTube and Tick Tock and I have a lot more
support to help navigate this constant only
changing landscape so I have come a long way
since that little green newbie posting blog
posts and videos in exchange for granola bars
or like free movie passes because granola bars
are delicious and I love me a good movie night
but these things don't pay my mortgage nor do
they pay my staff so that's just my back story
on my own Journey as a dietitian working in
the media but I now really want to talk about
this Washington Post article and I have some
big big thoughts so buckle up so in short this
article focused on social media videos created by
specific colleagues of mine who had partnered with
maybe what we would consider more controversial
commodity boards like American Beverage and the
Canadian sugar Institute the former campaign
focused on unpacking the whose concerns about
artificial sweeteners like aspartame and the
latter campaign was really focused on neutralizing
Extreme fear-mongering around sweets and sugar
the funny thing is I am on board with both of
these messages I certainly can't speak to all
the content pieces they reviewed or referenced
but just because something is sponsored by an
industry doesn't mean it's necessarily lies even
if they the industry itself is kind of assessed
so for example let's look at this real by Kara
harp street she literally explained why the who
headlines were misleading and alarmist considering
what they actually meant which was something that
at the time a lot of us science communicators did
including myself I basically said the exact same
thing and nobody fed me that script because I was
not sponsored to say it the headlines in my
opinion did not represent the data and then
this one from Jen The dietitian who gave some
really great suggestions for parents on how to
manage Halloween candy with their kids including
letting their kids eat whatever they want on day
one and two this again is literally the exact same
advice that I've given on my channel because it's
what Pediatric and family dietitians know works
best I scan through the other posts that were
mentioned here and while there are a few videos
that maybe messaging wise wouldn't be 100 on brand
for me but that's me dietitians are not some
homogeneous group of robots just regurgitating
the food guide we all have our own approaches to
interpreting and communicating the evidence just
because I personally can't see myself partnering
with these commodity boards because again they
don't fit the screening criteria that my team
and I have very carefully crafted for me I
don't think it's wrong to be paid to communicate
an evidence-based message that's on brand like
all these messages that I believe in but you know
who does not believe in them this guy right here
the lead author Anna had O'Connor anahad is well
known for his investigative journalism related to
the role of Industry funded research on sugar
and the Obesity epidemic which again explains
why this story was totally his beat and while he
may be a Yale graduate and taking down Big Sugar
maybe a special interest of his he actually has
no training or education in nutrition at all and
yet not only is he pretty much exclusively writing
about health and wellness for media Publications
but he somehow is qualified to write a whole book
about the foods you must eat and co-author another
book on weight loss again no qualifications
in the field I've also seen him interviewed
on podcasts and YouTube about nutrition as if
he is a nutrition expert and interestingly he
seems to focus on nutrition messaging that is at
odds with most major authorities recommendations
and therefore is at odds with most dietitians
recommendations that is from what I can see he
seems to to lean into a very restrictive like no
sugar full paleo hunter-gatherer kind of carnivore
leaning intermittent fasting diet so again once
I discovered this it totally made sense as to why
this whole article focused on the dangers of sugar
and aspartame it totally made sense why he called
out a handful of female dietitians who happened
to be largely anti-diet diet dietitians who were
sharing pretty neutral evidence-based information
what's kind of shady is he was ripping into them
for breaking down the who's sensationalized
headlines on aspartame and yet on July 12th he
basically did the same thing like one of his wapo
articles shared the exact same messages that my
colleagues shared interestingly I didn't see any
kind of disclosure on behalf of the journalists
related to his personal nutrition belief system
or the nutrition books that he's authored that
supports his approach which again were written
without education in the field I mean I feel
like that would have been good to know seeing as
that may have played a role in his interpretation
of the crime of course seeing a nutrition expert
suggests any amount of candy Halloween may seem
dangerous to a nutrition expert who vehemently is
against any or all sweets but just really ironic
that there's such a double standard here because
lack of disclosure was his other main point of
criticism and I actually agreed with him here the
suggestion that in some cases dietitians did not
make it super clear that their post were sponsored
or who their posts were sponsored by was shocking
to me you know I've trained and coached hundreds
of dietitians on best practices for media and
brand work because again I have had skin in this
game before day one and disclosure for dietitian
content creators is rule number one so to be
clear the dietitians did disclose by stating
sponsored or add in the description but they
either did not use the paid partnership tool or
they didn't tag the commodity board that sponsored
it and again I agree this is not ideal this is not
being super transparent this is definitely not
my practice when I work with Brands like I have
been so adamant about this when I do any kind of
colleague webinars or mentorships because when
other influencer or content creator dietitians
don't disclose it hurts us all it leads people to
not trust us exhibit a the moment this article
came out people ran to my aspartame Tick Tock
video and asked is this sponsored spoiler alert it
was not and there are videos posted from like more
alternative Wellness accounts where the comments
are definitively accusing me of being in the post
when it's like girl did you read it because that
is defamatory slanderous spreading misinformation
and quite frankly not fair even if you disagree
with my content as influencers themselves they
have a responsibility to be truthful and
fact-based or they are more at fault than
the RDS in this post but back to the piece and
the author you know I really do have to wonder
if this journalist had something just against our
DS across the board because I know a lot of RDS
who are not named in this article who did lengthy
interviews with the authors and none of them were
included possibly because it didn't help this
journalist's case I also know from expertise
that some Brands and commodity boards like
will push back when it comes to using the paid
partnership tool or being super explicit about
the actual sponsor which in the case of aspartame
was American Beverage and yeah it's still on us
to push them back and say no I want to be super
transparent I cannot tell you how hard I've had
to push Brands sometimes but the guy could have
also laid it into industry for their role in being
secretive or sus because it's not a coincidence
that all of these creators disclosed the exact
same way I wonder why but anyways bottom line
on the article I do not believe that the author
fairly represented the intentions or actions of
my colleagues but I do believe we should all be
cautious interpreting any of these kinds of pieces
as unbiased truth we all need to be more critical
consumers of what we read but back to me for like
a hot minute because I can only speak with 100
certainty about how I work as an RD working in
the media so a huge part part of my personal brand
has been honesty and transparency I can't speak
for all Rd content creators who are working with
Brands but that is huge for me so in the spirit
of transparency I'm going to tell you exactly how
things work behind the scenes over here step one
typically my agent will get an email from a brand
or an agency and that email will say something
like hi we love Abby we're a food or supplement
company whatever and we would love to sponsor one
of Abby's YouTube videos or a tick tock Etc here's
what we're looking for you know I don't actually
work with a ton of commodity boards or Industries
even though there are some that I fully believe in
but they just don't come my way very often anymore
but again I would be asking myself if the industry
or commodity helps Public Health in some way but
if it's a brand or product which is usually what
I work with I will look at the company's consumer
facing website look at the ingredients look at the
claims read third party testing reports by the
way this is a really easy way for me to suss out
which supplements we work with and don't work
with because I only work with companies that do
third party testing but anyway then I'll ask some
questions if I don't see what I need to see and if
anything seems off it's an immediate no sometimes
it's a really fast no that starts basically with
my agent so any heavy weight loss related apps or
supplements or scales she'll send it to me as like
a courtesy slash a laugh and are both kind of like
did they even bother to Google me and what I do
but anyways I would say the percentage of offers
that I get 80 to 90 of them die right here that's
how strict we are but assuming it passes my sniff
test I ask for two basic things I want to try the
product or service and I want to know what their
talking points are because sometimes a product may
seem totally fine and benign on paper but when I
see their messaging I'm like hell no the testing
part is self-explanatory I have to like it or if
it's not my style because I have my own little
preferences too I have to think that it could
be something that would be helpful for at least
some subset of my audience but the messaging
can get a little tricky so basically for brand
campaigns they send out a deck or a PowerPoint
or like a word doc with their key messages
and usually like a set of do's and don'ts for
things that you can or can't legally say it is
fully up to me now to take those messages and to
create a piece of content that communicates them
while still being true to my voice and ammo
often times some of the messages I see in the
deck are no for me and as I mentioned when I was
young and green I probably wasn't as bullish as
I am now about it but now I am never afraid to
completely change things Redline the [__] out
of it and push back so for example a lot of food
or supplement Brands will want me to say something
like other product is clean and you guys know and
I like that word so I say no or if they told me
that they wanted me to say that product will help
you detox I'll be like no we know that's BS and
sometimes they maybe want me to make a nutrition
claim that I don't feel is supported by enough
high quality evidence so I will skip that or I'll
suggest a claim that is supported by evidence and
sometimes we push back so hard we just can't reach
an agreement and we just have to walk away and I
know that I am lucky to be in a position where
I can be super super selective like this and
have the confidence to know my worth as a science
communicator but I have worked really hard to earn
your trust and it's ultimately worth so much more
to me than like a one-off ad read then it comes to
actually creating the content so sometimes they
have an angle that they're hoping to go for like
back to school or like a specific holiday but for
the most part I hold all creative control I pitch
a handful of Concepts that I think will work for
me and my audience and where it makes thematic
sense to include the brand and then I write the
script the Brand's job is simply to approve the
script I wrote for legal and accuracy reasons and
to prove the video that I shot again for legal and
accuracy reasons but I'm never letting a brand
tell me what to say how to say it or what the
video is even about and by the way this is why
I typically do like ad read Style on my YouTube
videos I don't want Brands to have a say in the
content that I put out there for you guys like I'm
really really really strict about protecting my IP
so it's like they sponsored a video but I'm still
100 in control and then it comes to posting so
we disclose both the dang partnership actually I
cannot tell you how many times brands have pushed
back because I always like to put the disclosure
like A.D in the first sentence the copy of the
post because that way you don't need to click see
more to understand and notice that it is sponsored
but a lot of the brands or agencies that I've
worked with will want me to kind of put it at the
very end with all the other hashtags and so that's
what most influencers do but according to the FTC
and also just like my basic morals I don't think
that is a clear transparent disclosure it needs to
be visible and while the paid partnership tool is
not mandatory I do think it adds a visual on the
video that again helps people clearly understand
and see that it is a paid partnership now the
other thing I want to clarify about us dietitian
influencers working with brands that I feel that
the Washington Post article misrepresented is
this idea that we're all just kind of working
with these Brands behind the scenes to push
some kind of sinister agenda that like the more
aspartame game that gets consumed the more money
we make I mean there may be dietitians out there
who are long-time ambassadors or spokespeople or
Affiliates for a commodity or brand which again
they should be legally disclosing every single
time that commodity or brand is mentioned but
that's not personally how I work I mean maybe
one day I'll sit on the board for a brand in
which case again you will know about it every
single time they're mentioned but for me each
individual piece of content is spelled out super
carefully in our contract so it's not just like
I'm always sneakily seeding messages in without
you knowing and I'm going to use Dairy as an
example because of all the brands or industries
that I've partnered with dairy content is arguably
the most controversial so first of all While I
Work Dairy well I 100 appreciate that Dairy is not
for everyone whether it's because you're vegan or
lactose intolerant or you just don't like it
but Dairy is a huge part of my family's diet
it's a major source of quality nutrition for me
and for many other there's a plethora of quality
unsponsored peer review research to support it
and the messaging is always evidence based not to
mention me eating dairy and sharing nutrition
education about Dairy doesn't mean I'm not
eating and not sharing nutrition education about
non-dairy Alternatives like look at my fridge I'm
an equal milk opportunist all of these things can
have their place and thinking one is nutritious
doesn't mean that Alternatives that people
depend on are bad and that is really important
here like I never talk up a product by putting an
alternative down because chances are I think both
are really great so this is very much on brand
for me and again I'm not getting like monthly cash
installments from the dairy industry to brainwash
my followers into eating more cheese if I'm being
paid by Dairy to talk about Dairy on Instagram you
will know it if I'm being paid by a cheese brand
you'll know it I am being paid on a per content
piece basis for that one random Tick Tock or that
one sponsor ad read on my YouTube channel so
I don't become richer if you eat more yogurt
there's literally no incentive for me for you to
buy Dairy over non-dairy I actually don't even get
any information on Roi when I do a campaign but
anyway what I am saying is that if I talk about
Dairy and the video doesn't say sponsored I'm not
being paid for it no one has looked at it and said
yep that looks good it's just what I'm eating or
doing or taking and if it says sponsored I'm being
paid for it I look at the messaging I craft the
content in my voice based on what I'm comfortable
with and they gave it a thumbs up before I post
in both cases the messaging is the same I like
Dairy so I talk about it both when I'm paid and
when I'm not being paid and again most of you
guys know I talk equally about non-dairy milk
Alternatives as well and know that if a brand
makes its way onto any of my channels it has been
heavily vetted specifically by me so the bottom
line is I was really hurt by this article I felt
that the author went into it with a clear agenda
against female diet petitions particularly
anti-dye diet dietitians because perhaps our
general messaging of balance doesn't align with
more extreme restrictive Fringe diet and again
this interest was never disclosed I only know
that because I had to do my own sneaky sleuthing
investigative journalism after hours and I also
thought that the tone really undermined a lot of
the important work that us female media dietitians
do and shamed us for seeking out any means to turn
the hard work that is science communication into a
career or side hustle it takes an enormous amount
of work to research and write evidence-based
nutrition content like a YouTube script requires
grad school dissertation level work and I post
two 20-minute YouTube videos a week two shorts
a week seven tick tocks a week three blog posts
plus up to 14 Instagram posts and floor knows
how many stories this is a job and YouTube ad rev
isn't what it used to be if you want really well
researched well well written content you have to
be okay with dietitians accepting sponsorships
that they feel represents their MO you do not have
to be okay with them being sneaky about it and not
disclosing nor should any of us be spreading myths
or disinformation that could harm the public but
I don't know like diffusing the panic over the
media reports about aspartame or telling parents
that restricting sugar to aggressively is bad is
not dangerous misinformation it's exactly what
I would tell people too what I am saying here is
that as dietitians we need to work for your trust
and I know that I've worked really really hard to
earn yours transparency honesty and evidence-based
practice that's what you've come to expect
from me and that is what you should continue
to expect from me but I would love to hear your
thoughts any questions any clarifications I'm
happy to go into more detail leave me a comment
below and don't forget to hit my description
for my free Hunger crushing combo ebook and I
will see you next time on Abby's kitchen bye
[Music]